If you've seen The Lego Batman Movie, you'll
know it includes not only super-well-known
villains like the Joker, but also an incredible
range of other villains from the DC Comics
rogues gallery.
And scattered throughout the movie, there
are also some cool voice cameos you might
not have taken in.
So, in this video, I'm gonna run through many
of those villains and cameos for you.
Quick warning, there are spoilers ahead, so
if you're not ready for those, get out of
Gotham by tapping or clicking here to watch
my spoiler-free LEGO Batman Movie review.
By the way, I'll have a great giveaway to
win a pair of awesome Lego Batman Movie books
on my Lego Batman easter egg video, so make
sure you subscribe and turn on your notifications
so you don't miss out!
Ok, let's start with the villains that the
Joker hires for his dastardly attack on the
Gotham Energy Facility at the beginning of
the movie.
The first celebrity cameo is by talk show
host Conan O'Brien who voices The Riddler,
and he's joined by Scarecrow who masquerades
as a pizza delivery guy and is voiced by comic
actor Jason Mantzoukas.
Doug Benson voices Bane and does a good job
sounding very similar to Tom Hardy's take
on the character in The Dark Knight Rises.
Classic Batman villain Two-Face is played
by Billy Dee Williams, who voiced his iconic
Star Wars character Lando Calrissian in the
first Lego Movie and he also played Harvey
Dent in the 1989 Batman movie.
In fact, Williams had hoped Harvey Dent would
become Two-Face in the sequel Batman Returns,
but the character was dropped from that movie,
and when Two-Face did appear in Batman Forever,
he was played by Tommy Lee Jones.
Catwoman, who helps the villains hack in to
the system, is voiced by Zoe Kravitz, who's
starred in X-Men: First Class and the Divergent
series.
Indeed, Kravitz actually has some shocking
prior history with the Batman franchise, specifically
The Dark Knight Rises, which she was informed
she couldn't audition for a small part in
because, to quote what she was told, "they
weren't 'going urban'".
The comedy-folk duo Garfunkel and Oates each
voice a villain in the movie, with Riki Lindhome
as Poison Ivy and Kate Micucci as Clayface.
And rounding out The Joker's posse of major
villains is Harley Quinn voiced by Jenny Slate,
who was also the voice of Bellwether in Zootopia
and Gidget in The Secret Life of Pets.
The Lego Batman Movie also pays homage to
an enormous stack of villains from Batman's
Rogues Gallery.
Some are more familiar, like Penguin, who
turns up in a Lego version of his duck car
that we saw on screen in Batman Returns; there's
also Killer Croc, who we last aw in the Suicide
Squad movie, who exclaims "I did something"
when he switches on the bomb here; and there's
Mr Freeze who has a touch of Arnold Schwarzenegger
from Batman and Robin about him when he says
"no, you freeze".
Red Hood also turns up in a blink-and-you'll-miss-him
moment during a fight scene.
The official Lego site describes this Red
Hood as a "mysterious super-villain" and adds
that "rumors suggest that [he] may have a
secret connection to Batman or one of his
arch-villains."
In the comics, Red Hood is an alias that has
been used by different characters, two significant
ones being the Joker and Jason Todd.
The Lego Jason Todd version of Red Hood has
already appeared in the Lego video games with
a drastically different look to this Red Hood
in the Lego Batman movie.
And, the helmet, cape and bow-tie worn by
the Red Hood that appears in The Lego Batman
Movie suggest that this is the Joker Red Hood
rather than Jason Todd.
In the comics, Red Hood was also an alias
the Joker used for his criminal activities
before he became the Joker.
Other villains who appear on screen very briefly
include Captain Boomerang, aka Digger, who
gets kicked in the head by Batman in the movie.
In the comics, he's a criminal who uses high-tech
boomerangs, and we last saw him on the big
screen played by Jai Courtney in the Suicide
Squad movie.
There's also Man-Bat, who first appeared in
the comics in 1970 as Kirk Langstrom, a scientist
who accidentally turns himself into a bat.
Man-Bat hasn't appeared yet in a live-action
Batman film despite being considered for various
cancelled Batman projects.
The closest thing so far has been the bat
creature that attacked Bruce Wayne during
his nightmare in Batman V Superman.
Perhaps one of the daftest villains in The
Lego Batman Movie, although frankly that's
a tough call, is Condiment King.
He first appeared in Batman: The Animated
Series and has often been used for comedic
effect, with an emphasis on condiment-inspired
puns.
The character was later introduced into the
comics under the name of Mitchell Mayo.
King Tut is a Batman villain that was initially
created for the 1960s Batman TV series, and
was later adapted in the comic books.
King Tut, aka William McElroy, was an Egyptologist
at Yale who transformed into a delusional
villain when he lost his mind after being
hit on the head during a student riot.
Egghead, who turns ups in The Lego Batman
Movie egging the bat signal, is another villain
who appeared in the 1960s Batman TV series,
where he was played by Vincent Price.
Killer Moth first appeared in Batman issue
63 where he set himself up as the opposite
of Batman, helping Gotham's criminal underworld.
Killer Moth also had a fake identity as a
rich guy called Cameron van Cleer and, similar
to Batman, he had a Mothmobile as well as
a Moth-signal that criminals used to call
him.
Kite-Man, aka Charles Brown in the comics,
is said to be partly inspired by the Peanuts
character Charlie Brown who struggled to fly
a kite.
Kite-Man first appeared in 1960 in Batman
issue 133, and, as you can guess, he uses
kite-based weapons to fight Batman.
Gentleman Ghost is a supernatural villain
in the comics who was created when the thief
Jim Craddock was hanged by the gunfighter
Nighthawk.
Polka-Dot Man is a Batman villain who, in
the comics, can transform the coloured dots
on his tricked-out costume into various weapons.
Catman first appeared in Detective Comics
in 1963 and modelled his look on a combo of
Batman and Catwoman.
March Harriet is based on the comic-book villain
Harriet Pratt, aka March Hare, who along with
Tweedledum, Tweedledee, and the Mad Hatter
was part of the Wonderland Gang.
The villainous Zebra Man has appeared in several
different versions in the comics.
In his first incarnation, he invented a machine
that charged his body with energy, which gave
him his powers and stripes.
He also wore a special belt to control his
body's powerful diamagnetic force.
The Eraser is a villain whose costume includes
a mask with a giant eraser on top.
And, suitably enough, he hires himself out
to criminals to erase evidence left at crime
scenes.
Orca is the scientist Dr Grace Balin who experimented
with spinal cord regeneration after she was
paralysed.
She transformed into an orca-human hybrid
after experimenting with orca tissue.
The comic-book version of Tarantula who appears
in the movie is the former FBI agent Catalina
Flores, who takes the law into her own hands
to deal with corrupt police officers and criminals.
Clock King is a foe of Green Arrow in the
comics and used his clock and time-based skills
to turn to crime as a way to support his sister
when he was mistakenly diagnosed with a terminal
illness.
And Calendar Man is a date-obsessed villain
whose crimes relate to specific dates and
holidays.
Now, the Lego Batman Movie doesn't restrict
itself to villains from DC Comics, TV shows
or movies.
In fact, the Phantom Zone is home to a number
of trapped non-DC villains.
Comedian Eddie Izzard provides the voice of
Voldemort delivering some great lines like
"stop moving around, muggles", and he also
uses the levitation charm "Wingardium Leviosa"
several times in the movie.
I wonder what Ralph Fiennes, who plays Alfred
in this film and brought Voldemort to life
in the Harry Potter movies, thought of Eddie
Izzard's take on the character!
Jemaine Clement, who you'll have heard recently
as the rather shiny crab Tamatoa in Moana,
delivers a comedic animated version of Sauron
from The Lord of the Rings.
The iconic ape King Kong also appears and
is voiced by Seth Green.
Ellie Kemper, who you might know as The Unbreakable
Kimmy Schmidt or as Erin from The Office,
lends her voice to Phyllis, the brightly coloured
brick who serves as the gatekeeper to the
Phantom Zone.
There's also a bunch of other cool villains
including Doctor Who's Daleks, a velociraptor from
Jurassic Park, Jaws, Medusa, the Gremlins,
Dracula, Agent Smith from The Matrix, and
the Wicked Witch of the West also makes an
appearance with her flying monkeys.
The hilarious Justice League anniversary party
scene also brings back some characters and
voices from the first Lego Movie.
Channing Tatum returns as the voice of Superman,
and Jonah Hill and Adam Devine are back as
Green Lantern and The Flash respectively.
Other Justice League members at the party
include Wonder Woman, Aquaman, Cyborg, Martian
Manhunter who jokingly dubs himself Martian
Dancehunter, Green Arrow, Black Canary, Hawkman
& Hawkgirl, the Wonder Twins & Gleek, Black
Vulcan, Apache Chief, El Dorado, and Wonder
Dog.
And in Gotham city, there are a few more celebrity
cameos.
Singer Mariah Carey is the voice of Mayor
McCaskill, the retiring Commissioner Jim Gordon
is played by Pretty Woman's Hector Elizondo,
Chris Hardwick of Nerdist fame is one of the
reporters quizzing Barbara Gordon after the
Joker surrenders, and The Lego Batman Movie
director Chris McKay is Pilot Bill who argues
with the Joker about why Batman will foil
his evil plans.
Now, did you have a favourite cameo in the
movie?
And if there's a Lego Batman sequel, who would
you like to see have more screen time?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
if you hit that thumbs up button, share and
subscribe.
You can also tap or click here for more of
my videos including all the best easter eggs
from The Lego Batman Movie.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!